hey guys dog walker here looking brace
Guzzi because i'm just about to do a bum
review on what movie you may ask Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles of course and you
might be wondering where Rob is uh he on
principle will not review this movie
because of this remark that Michael Bay
made when transformers 4 was coming out
say hey oh you guys will hate it but
you'll still go see it and Rob just said
no I won't so there's a Michael Bay
movie he's not interested in doesn't
want support he won't go see it to prove
that that is what makes the big
difference and generally my rent for
that so good for you but I gotta go see
it I because it's kind of my job to see
bad movies and to report on them and
talk about them and say what the hell
does that mean if they're a hit or
they're not a hit or that this is what
we consider entertainment um so before
we go into that you probably wanna know
a little bit history about Ninja Turtles
and me because that plays a big part in
whether or not you're gonna like this
movie I think um I huge into Ninja
Turtles huge I loved the cartoon the
original cartoon loved the original
comic the really gory one with blood is
black for some reason it's weird um like
the adventure comics I had a collection
of Ninja Turtle toys in this Ninja
Turtle laundry bag that was like double
the size of me at that time so love
Ninja Turtles absolutely obsessed but
loved the movies until three came out
and that's when I started to lose as I
think a lot of kids did they start to
grow out a fan said whatever fun little
time in our life but it's done uh and in
the past what 20 years it's gone through
so many reincarnations this is I mean
like Batman and Superman and spider-man
so I mean they've gone through a lot of
reincarnation but they've been around
for like you know years and years and
years and turtles is still pretty young
when you think about and it's still kind
of going it's going through all these
different revisions who the hell would
have thunk would have thought that um
and I've kind of kept out of the loop
for that simply cuz it's just not my
thing anymore it Turtles will always
have a place in my
I'm always going to remember those
memories and you know even the first
film the live-action watch is not
technically a good film but I'm still
gonna love it it's it still turtles to
me I look at go wow there's Michelangelo
Donatello it's always have a place in my
heart but it's I haven't kept up I know
there's a new show now um and they had
TMNT the movie and they've done like ice
all these different and they had a
nother hand-drawn animated one just
they've gone through so many revisions
most of them are here or good again it
just not my thing right now um but but I
hear they're good and people were so
pissed off when they saw Michael Bay was
behind this new one he was going to make
them aliens and they changed that
obviously uh so going into this film I I
definitely have a history but I was not
I'm not a purist I'm not so on that says
oh it has to be this way cuz I've seen
all the different versions they've done
you know April's a teenager now like in
the new show in the CG show you know
when everybody is that you can't have
Megan Fox as a frolic but you she's a
teenager now you know it's it's but okay
we'll get to that so I went into this
movie really wide to hate it actually
mostly because I am so sick of the
boredom that is Michael Bay I always say
he is made it boring to be a man now all
the stereotypical man stuff that you
know we used to love we used to love
explosions we used to love jumping in
slow-mo we used to love budgie it's all
boring now thank you Michael Bay you
have totally sucked out the fun of that
uh and I really thought this was going
to be the exact same thing it was gonna
be transformers five just with turtles
and parts of it are actually many parts
are I'm not gonna lie but going into
this it's both a little better and a
little worse than I thought it was going
to be um I try think even where to start
well first off they had an advertisement
for turtles - this was a Hollywood
Boulevard they're having the guy you
play like the super shredder is going to
come there and hand advertising for
turtles - you can't no you can't do that
got you can't show those incredible
animatronic those incredible costumes
before this CGI shit you can't I
Oh that hurt the movie big-time when you
just see cuz the turtles in the first
two films especially the first one are
amazing they're amazing looking and you
know that when this film starts this new
Turtles
what you're seeing is never there and
it's never gonna look like it's there uh
so yeah I of course don't like the fact
that they're CGI and I know it's
everywhere now but it's I'm not gonna
like that
um and it's just okay quick subject
change if you go and find the blu-ray
for Ninja Turtles by the way the first
film and you look on the back and they
have the turtles from Turtles three on
the back I'm just gonna say just on
behalf of the memory of Jim Henson fuck
you like a big fuck you to that because
those costumes you know all the budget
went into those costumes in the first
film and they look amazing and they are
so well done they still hold up and you
know they're just like oh the neutrals
is coming out we have to make that look
good because we know the CGI is shed but
we got to make it look good so let's uh
let's just grab the ones from the third
film and put them in the back of the box
fuck you really long and hard fuck you
cuz those costumes are wonderful and for
any of the region you should check out
the film just to see the puppetry it's
amazing um but anyway you are here about
this film so every single time there's
something like a good change I'm open to
change and there are some good changes
in this every time they do something
that's like a good change and kind of
clever they do something that's like Oh
typical Michael Bay bullshit and it's so
inconsistent and the short version if
you just want the cliff notes if you
want come on get to the point the movies
not good it it's not um but with that
said as someone who kind of acknowledges
that Ninja Turtles is a stupid idea
anyway again
love them love with all my heart but
it's a stupid idea um there's a lot of
stuff they do is actually kind of clever
for example you know a Megan Fox is a
brony all
went to that first uh everyone say it's
a terrible choice it's not the best
choice it's not very good but to her
credit there's a lot of scenes where I I
could see how it could have worked
especially one starts out like you have
her bugging people all the time for the
story it changed miss O'Neil don't you
ever give up yet yo tab might phones you
follow me everywhere you blah blah blah
and then that feels right and there's a
lot of times particularly early on again
where she's kind sneaking around and
like other people are lined up to talk
to a prison she'll sort of like you know
count in front of them and that that's
April O'Neil that's very clever
and I also like how when it starts off
you see that she's mostly doing kind of
like Good Morning America stories like
you know ooh let's see how to exercise
with the trampoline don't I look goofy
haha nobody takes me seriously and she
doesn't like that bet that's a good
setup like this is clever stuff um but
then there's other scenes where like or
Splinter who walks butt-ugly it looks
really bad he looks like the toy the
original toy of Splinter if you ever go
back and find that that's what it looks
like um like he's in trouble or sight
she'll just come and go splinter and
Waka and it's no come on where's that
energy where's that you know excitement
you head of a few seconds ago and it's
really inconsistent um and kind of same
thing will arnett is kind of like the
comic relief in this and he's kind of
the same way sometimes he'll get a laugh
and then other times you're like really
that's the joke you're leaving on that
that's the button at the end of that
scene okay I know you're funny I don't
know why you're not being funny here
they're not letting you or whatever but
yeah so that's really inconsistent uh
but when you see the shredder like
without the costume my first thought was
boy this could work like they mostly
keep them in shadow but you can make him
out just enough he's got kind of these
scars he's got this deep booming voice
but not cartoony deep like in the first
film you know where it's like how does
he have that voice there's no way to
have that voice uh you know we're in the
when we put the outfit on as we as the
deep booming voice and it sounds
manipulating robotic but he looks
robotic so it kind of makes sense his
evil plan makes no sense
um his uh Oh wasn't it William Fincher I
think is his name uh he's the only thing
that is consistently great throughout
this because he is just hamming it up
like mad and he is having a great time
with his performance and he's kind of
like the business end to the shredder um
and the plan makes no sense whatsoever
they like both of them want to destroy
or put out this like evil disease it's
going to kill a lot of New York so that
uh Fincher has like the antidote which
he has to get from the Turtles of course
to spread to all the people to save New
York in which case that will give him
and the shredder rule of New York
because he'll have so much money even
though he already has so much money
anyway
to do all this he can create a super
shredder suit it's like how what else do
you need uh you already have this crime
organization called the foot call
because they step on people and oppress
them that's the bullshit reason um and
they use guns which on the one hand it's
like wow it's not very ninja light but
on the other hand kind of makes sense um
so and so I'm saying to myself boy that
makes no sense whatsoever that is a
terrible stupid plan I felt back to the
first film and I thought it was the
shredders plan in that still shit was
that really that great a plan either
it's even the second with the revenge
yeah and then what what's your oh what
are you doing so in many ways this film
kind of made me realize some of the
faults of you know the the original
setup of turtles to all the turtles
films and the cartoon and stuff I mean
stuff that like I said I always knew
didn't make sense but and they they
tried to fix up uh April actually has a
connection to the turtles before um
before running into him like she was
actually the daughter of a science
who is doing these mutations and the
turtles were there uh which made more
sense than whatever it ran into a
fishbowl or whatever this makes a lot
more sense uh and she's there and she
names them all after the Renaissance
painters cuz doesn't she look like
someone who'd be into the Renaissance
painters
um again if they wrote her that way
great but they don't you know she's
smart but she's not she's and she
wouldn't know the Renaissance painters
um but she made them michelangelo
donatello and stuff and she feeds them
the little pizza and everything so it's
on the one hand I could see someone very
easily not liking that but I thought it
was kind of clever I thought was clever
giving a connection before she actually
sees them when they're mutants um and it
would have worked better if there was
more of a connection between them like
in the original cartoon you see April's
showing them around and telling them how
things work you know that was kind of
her purpose um in the film like Cara
Mayer she did I think she kind of did um
you know she was always there gateway
into the human world uh and here she
it's really not it's she gets some
information to help them out actually
she saves them more than the turtle save
her which I thought was kind of cool um
so there's all these little changes
going on that I think are kind of clever
and kind of smart and even the way the
turtles look which I miss the snails I
miss the big noses I think if they had
that honestly I would had no problem
with their design uh but yeah the fact
that they're flat may got those two
little holes and it's they look ugly
they look really ugly but when you take
that out I like that they add more stuff
to their identity a Leonardo has this
very sort of samurai look you know and
this chest and the source and everything
Michelangelo is more the surfer so he
has kind of like this beaded necklace
and kind these tattoos and stuff and
Raphael is more the real tough guy so he
you know he's got the bigger muscles
he's got kind of the headband as well
dontel is the science person so he's got
all the
sighs gear on him constantly I thought
that was smart I thought was really
clever because the turtles in the movie
the first movie like they do make the
faces a little different so you can tell
then the cartoon it's just the color of
a mask like nothing else I mean there's
different personalities but looking at
them it's you take out the color you
can't tell which is which
uh you know oh that one has the swords
it still doesn't count um so I thought
that was very clever um the big failing
point in this film is they're trying to
build up the connections uh between
everybody you know it's about family
it's about even they even do the big
stupid moral at the end where it's like
you know I now I know it's about
trusting one another it yeah okay
whatever turtles don't need a moral
really it's there and they don't need it
in a Michael Bay production you know um
but it's supposed to be kind of about
that connection and there really is not
much of a connection
April does even though they establish
more of a connection
story-wise uh she really doesn't have
that much of a connection to them um you
know you don't marry much of the
interaction off of them and we won't
blame Fox for that or the writing it or
maybe both that I don't know but they
don't much of a connection
the turtles themselves particularly
Raphael who ever since the first film
it's like I get it they didn't want
Raphael Michael Raphael Michelangelo the
cartoon we're too similar you know
they're both kind of goofy funny guys
you know one's a little dumber and one's
a little bit more cynical like that's it
so it made sense to have one that was
kind of like the Wolverine the rogue and
then one knows all the goofy smart alec
stuff and so Raphael has always kind of
been the loner jerk uh which is not a
bad idea I'm not against that but like
the exposition in this like as soon as
they're done doing the first big fight
you know they get back home and
Raphael's like yeah things would be
different
what do you mean when I'm out of here
and running on my own and stuff it's
like it's so painful that exposition
there's a lot of scenes like that uh and
the only
that can make it work again simply
because he's just yucking it up is the
scientist guy Fincher whatever it's just
like when this is done I'm gonna be rich
like stupid rich it's you can just Dahle
doesn't care but he's having fun with it
um so that's or the the big missing
point even the connection with the
shredder who by the way when he gets the
costume on well I was laughing so hard
it is so Michael Bay's shredder just a
void of anything original anything
interesting
just big penis envy shredders just like
mussels that means it's good just think
about makes me laugh and of course like
you got shredders a great design
I mean LK McCartney looks very silly you
know but like in in the movie and in the
comics it's a great design it's sort of
this metal samurai and these sharp you
know
these sharp points and these great
curves and the spikes on the I mean it's
it's great up and they just made him
into every other boring video game
villain um and that's kind of a shame
because I thought the designs of the
turtles for the most part were kind of
fun they could have had fun with
shredder but no they just make him Robo
shredder and Lenny's in the shredder
suit he's he's every other bad guy you
would forget him instantly and you don't
forget shredder I mean even in the
cartoon it's like he's he's still
unforgettable and this he you just
forgive the second you see him um a
minute splinter have a PHY splinter uses
his tail now
like I can't traditional Michael Bay
bullshit like his tail reaches out I can
grab people around the neck and smashed
up against the wall it's really funny um
it but it's meant to be cool but it's
not it's funny uh so the interaction
offer them the interaction was fun
the interaction with the shredder the
interaction with April there's no
connection emotionally with them I think
that's the real big element missing is
because that was the fun of the turtles
is seeing them all interact off each
other help shredder and Krang like
they're pathetic villains but you loved
watching them interact off each other
like that was the that was a big part of
it not the only part but a big part and
they try to force this stuff in most the
time it doesn't work there's a scene at
the end where they're falling off this
cliff and they think they're all gonna
die Raphael finally admits you know that
all I just didn't die at all the times I
was me and it's because I was afraid and
I really love you guys we know you
dumbass movie even kids no you don't
need to Dark Knight it and do bullet
points of every single thing that you're
feeling and thinking it just No let the
movie speak for itself we'll let it have
a moment you want to know the best
interaction in this movie the part where
I said wow like that was not only Ninja
Turtles but that was them really
connecting as like brothers and a unit
and a family and everything and it's
it's a really silly scene but and you
might laugh but it's a scene where it's
just before the great big fight like
their gut they're in this elevator and
they're going up to fight the shredder
and they're in there and they're just
waiting and you know the elevators going
Bing Bing Bing and they're just sitting
there it's a still shot fucking heaven
forbid remember those those can still
exist um and and I know why they don't
do still shots either because it's
always like I'll get today's I get okay
so it's a still shot them and the
elevator and the things dinging and
Michelangelo just with nunchucks just
goes boop boop boop boop boop boop and
they can look at and you would think cuz
what they've been doing throughout the
resume they just go mouki whomp and
that's a connection but know that he's
doing it Raphael's there you know the
real gruff one you know no fun Raphael
and he goes
to to to to to Leonardo's there sir
looks over with his sword I'm just all
serious just goes
yeah and Donna tells her to and they get
a song going before the big battle and
it's you know they don't bring in the
actual you know the orchestra doesn't
come in and play music they just keep it
quiet and it's they start singing a
little bit and then they reach the boy
my god and they go up wonderful moment
it was funny it showed how they
connected it was clever and it was done
in one shot and he did have to rely on
any gimmicks it was just a funny genuine
moment and there's so few of those in
this movie but I will say I thought
there would be none none like that
whatsoever and there's one or two um
there's a few moments where I did feel
okay like that's that's Michelangelo
okay but that's Donna tell like they're
a little different but they they got it
in that scene their scenes where they
get it and again for a guy who thought
there would be nothing this would be the
ultimate boring film there's many boring
parts uh but there are some scenes where
they got it right and I why knowledge
when they do get it right uh now for
scenes where they get it wrong I'm going
to go back to that camera thing why are
there always so many times in Michael
Bay productions ah the camera always
moving a like for example there's a
scene where just a newscast is going on
and you just see the reporters that
reports talk and they're just like now
this happened in the news today let me
tell you about and then you'll have a
person watching it's like wow I'm
listening to them listen to that right
now
and then you have like a farm shout like
this and everyone will just feel like
you know wow holy smokes I can't believe
what's going on here and then you'll
have a spinning chat like this like my
god this means the end of civilization
as we know it and it's it's all these
fucking gimmicks and it looks nice but
you go why I'll tell you why because the
whoever producers directors or whatever
very much Bay I mean this is Bay's
bullshit he like just exploit this to
the nth degree and the reason why is
because he thinks that the camera angles
doing that well
up for the fact that there is nothing on
screen of potential it is masking the
fact that the film it really is penis MV
because the film cannot hold you with
just its characters and it's writing it
can't cuz there's nothing there
so and even sometimes when there is
something there they don't want to take
the chance they don't want to risk it
you know because they are that insecure
of their product that's what people what
people are missing they think that by
having the big explosions and having the
cameras constantly moving that they're
wow they really want to show how big and
major this is no they're actually very
badly masking that they have nothing and
that's what people really got to see um
when you take that out of it there
there's nothing there hell I think that
those tricks are drawing big arrows
saying we got nothing we got nothing we
are empty we are only doing what focus
groups tell us sell that this is not
poetry this is math this is blank plus
blank equals blank not someone
expressing something so you need to
figure that out if you don't want to see
any more of it um but and in my opinion
we are seeing much less uh I get with
the Marvel movies and so on I mean we
animated films that we're seeing much
less of this which i think is great uh
you just got to see it with bay guys i
mean and it will fade i mean that's
that's is sir the one thing that's kind
of uplifting is that this will all go
away
uh this is a fad it really is it's a fad
going long but it's it people are gonna
wake up they're already waking up you
know like I said we're getting good
action movies we're getting care at
working movies with good characters and
doing stuff that's different and well
Michael Bay and his dollars will keep
throwing stuff at what you've already
seen at some point you're gonna get
bored uh it's called evolving and a lot
of us
it wants to a primal
and just want to see you know primals
good we need to survive but a lot of
people are just going to want to stay in
that one part and see the same thing
over and over and over uh but most of us
we want more and that is what's
happening because I think we are getting
better action films um but I really went
off on a rant here sorry BAE does that
um I never met the guy but he just
brings out these fascinating emotions
and the manipulation of the young mostly
um and I just I just find it fascinating
so anywho um the one last thing I'll
talk about which is important to talk
about is the action in the movie uh
there's a scene that there's two really
big action scenes uh and they're
probably three there there's one where
they break into the turtles home and
it's just shaky-cam bright light can't
see a thing
it's stupid there's one cool scene where
shredder tries to attacks players player
does even lucky ass oh sorry just like
two two two two two
that was cool um but it's every other
boring dumb Michael Bay trick - oh and
then your fight back up of the zoo your
fight my bike boring uh then the second
big action sequence comes up and this is
them going down a they're going down
this big cliff as big snowy cliff and
it's actually well done and I'll get
back to that a second and then you get
the big fight at the very end which is
just a fight on top of a building sounds
familiar
ah and it's it's like you're watching
nothing you're just watching cartoons
fight each other and big wall Pooh cares
I was asking myself why did that snow
sequence work why did I get involved in
it why did I laugh at that why did I go
wow and all these thing cuz I I know
it's not there you know it's all CG but
why was I getting into that and I
realize it's two things one it's it's a
different scenario it's them constantly
sliding down uh and then trying to work
out be creative how they're gonna get
out of a predicament if someone's like
shoo
something is going to electrocute
somebody you know how do you get that
off how do you fight them how do you do
while going down this cliff constantly
so it's and there's a lot of scenes of
them sliding down stuff and those scenes
seem to work and lysa it's not only the
creativity but I realize uh when you
have the speed of that going when you're
constantly moving at that speed gravity
doesn't play as big a part maybe it
plays a bigger part than expected
because you're going so fast so when you
hit something you're going to still keep
projecting forward so the weight of it
isn't as big a deal in fact if anything
it's more fun when they hit something
and they go spinning or they flip over
or something like that in all the other
action sequences there's no respect for
that gravity there's no respect to how
much these characters way or again maybe
it's a mathematical way to well know a
character this big would naturally jump
this I but know it's you're doing the
math again it's not the poetry when a
character is jumping and fighting the
shredder there is no weight tooling
because you know it's a cartoon and
you're just going to see them fight
what's the most boring part of a cartoon
when they're just when they're doing
regular fighting that the vet that's
really boring but when they're doing
something cartoony that you haven't
really seen before that's interesting
like them sliding down the cliff uh so
anytime there's just they're straight on
fighting it's not very interesting but
anytime they have a different scenario
where the animation can really shine
that's great if we taught Jackie Chan
doing kung fu that'd be cool because Ava
put a lot of work and effort into it and
B it's really there it's amazing to
watch it because you know it's not an
illusion they're really fighting and
when one hand is blocked like this
that's really blocking in Ninja Turtles
you're watching a cartoon when you see
this it's not there and you know it's
not there so you have to make up for
that by giving creative scenarios and
the cliff was a creative scenario and it
was so creative that the illusion works
better because they're constantly going
downhill so it can mask
ah the fact that they don't have the
weight down and they don't have the
gravity down of it so the action for the
most part is very boring but there's one
or two scenarios where they do something
kind of clever even Splinter with the
dumbass tail uh it's kind of fun to see
him he's fighting one guy then his tail
can grab another guy constantly keep
smashing into the ground it's that's
creative it's stupid again it's Ninja
Turtles you know it's kinda comes with
the territory
um and yeah so every single time there
was something that kind of worked or
what's kind of clever like I remember
when she goes to the prison charge of
Channel six it's actually called Channel
six this time I don't know why they
always did a different channel but uh
when she goes to channel six and says no
no I found turtles and and I have the
picture it's a really bad picture it's
blah blah blah
I'll say to myself well she be fired
sure enough vaccine she's carrying her
stuff out she's fired I'm like oh okay
you know like they're at you serve
accounting for this but then you'll have
something that makes no fucking sense at
all like there's this uh the shredders
assistant I guess I don't know where the
head of the foot kind of and she's this
cool looking way she's got like this
pink stripe in her hair and she's got
this great tough looking sound like ooh
now who's this character gonna be she's
gonna be real good she does like nothing
I mean she is almost entirely pointless
you could have cut her out in this
nothing so it every single time there's
a good step like something that's kind
of clever
it balances out by having something
Michael Bay stupid bullshit I just want
to clarify
every time I can't tell when Michael Bay
has something good to offer to the film
cuz maybe he does Annie it's really mean
to say like everything he has is a bad
idea
there could have been recommendations he
had they're good recommendations but the
thing is you can't tell when they're the
good recommendations but you can always
tell when they're the bad
recommendations you can look at a scene
of really lame action and boring ethics
and the music going you know when really
nothing is going on you know but they
want you to think something is going on
and that's Michael Bay um so it this may
sound really really scatterbrain and I
will say I really wanted to kind of hate
it I want to hate it for being really
really boring and for me watching
nothing on it like I said I was gonna
get transformers 5 and it's there's more
thought put into it then people are
probably giving it credit for it if
you're a Turtles fan if you're not if
you never heard of Turtles this is
stupid don't even try it you're not
gonna get into it at all it is fucking
dumb don't waste your time if you know
Charles Phan at all um my Eve you never
heard of there whatever in terms of
other turtles fan it's it's just gonna
depend on you because there's so many
incarnations of the Ninja Turtles I
can't it's so strange but there are so
many different incarnations and
depending on your connection to them
what you think they should be you're all
just going to have a different reaction
to this movie um and I don't think it I
don't even think it's gonna be like
split right down the middle where either
people love it or hate it I think it's
going to be like everyone's gonna kind
of like it but then hate this stuff or
kind of hate it but really like this day
I think it's gonna be all over the map
um but I'm I'm glad it's at least that
instead of just a bore fest like I just
watch nothing uh so I do really give it
credit for that I don't think it's a
good movie um and it's it's still dumb
but there's more thought put into it
then that least I thought I was going to
get for a Michael Bay production so yeah
that's about it this has probably been a
really long V log here but until a
scatterbrain but yeah it's I don't know
it it played with my thoughts on Ninja
Turtles and this movie in a way I didn't
think it was going to and I I give it
credit for at least doing that so take
it for what it's worth hopefully you can
figure out if this will be the film for
you and I'll just see you guys later
take care